we're going to begin this hour with the
continuing concerns about the impact of
this pandemic on the mental health and
academic performance of students we're
all thinking about that a survey by
mackenzie and company found that by the
end of school year last year students
between kindergarten through 12th grade
or on average think about this five
months behind in math and four months
behind on reading joining us now is
education secretary miguel cardona for
an interview you'll see only on cbs
mornings good morning mr secretary it's
nice to see you in person we only see
you from here oh i know good morning
great you're a real boy it's nice to
have you here at the table but let's
pick up that uh pick up about students
mental health what needs to be done what
can be done what should be done about
students mental health parents very
concerned about it they are concerned
all ages they are concerned a lot more
has to be done right uh we you know at
the department we we put out first of
its kind
guidance last year on how to support
students as they come back in uh you
know the american rescue plan provide
130 billion dollars and we really
prioritize ensuring that students and
families have access to better mental
health supports we've seen examples of
that across the country i have to say
educators are continue to impress me
with what they're doing whether it's
providing mental health supports in
schools after school programming but i
think it's critical that in this next
phase of recovery where we are you know
our schools are open
as we're talking about recovery we have
to make sure that the foundation of this
recovery is the mental health supports
that our students need
yeah i mean i saw a great story this
morning about a teacher um who just
takes her kids one by one and walks them
around the building and allows them to
talk
can we go to student loans we've had
many many older students reach out to us
about forgiving student loan debt and i
think that student loan debt uh
americans owe nearly 1.6 trillion
dollars in student loans there has been
talk about forgiving student loan debt
where does the biden administration
stand on that now yeah we're definitely
since day one making sure that we put
our borrowers and our students at the
center of the conversations in just one
year um president biden has forgiven
over 17 billion dollars already but
couldn't he take action now and forgive
it you know we're having those
conversations now um it's certainly
something that where we have the ability
to address uh where colleges might have
taken advantage or
loan services have taken advantage of
borrowers we're releasing and
discharging those debts and we're going
to continue the conversations about over
overall broad debt relief but i don't
want to uh i i think the culture in our
administration and in the department is
one of putting students first that's why
the public service loan forgiveness
program which was set up over 10 years
ago didn't work and in one year we got
it going we got over 700 000 people
further along in relief uh than they
were before so we're proud of that yeah
senator elizabeth warren was here and
she said the biden administration has
the power to with a stroke of a pen
erase federal student loans it sounds
like you want to do that but you don't
want to get ahead of your ball no i mean
the reality is it's it's uh we also want
to make sure that our colleagues on the
hill uh continue to fight for for that
as well
and
we know in the administration we have a
responsibility to put our students first
we think the higher education system
needs work uh we think the loan process
needs work we're
working on it so to make sure that the
system doesn't go back to where we were
too so
uh in five years from now we don't want
to be in the same position we're in so
loan forgiveness is one thing but fixing
the broken system is something that
we've been working on as well mr
secretary you've been very outspoken
about florida's don't say gay bill you
called it hateful um does the department
of education plan to take any action
against this law and i know you've
spoken to some parents about it what did
they tell you you know yesterday i had a
moving
very emotional conversation with
students parents educators from florida
and i think the words of the students uh
are most impactful i had a 12th grader
who shared that um
he knew he was different since he was
five he said this is pure hatred uh i
had a parent saying
please don't use my children as a pawn
in your political games so for me this
is about protecting all students i i
feel frustrated you know across the
world we see
we know we don't like bullies right
but yet right in our own backyard it's
happening there are over 12 states that
are passing or trying to pass
legislation like this we need to protect
our students we need to protect our
students including our lgbtq students
what can you do and educators well what
we're doing is we're lifting up their
voices we're ensuring that uh the office
of civil rights is is ready if
complaints come forward in the
implementation of this but we're sending
the message that it's unacceptable to to
bully marginalized students already we
talk about mental health right you know
students who are gay or transgender um
uh are need and need more mental health
supports
and it's really important that while
we're providing those supports we're
also not sending them to an environment
where they're feeling marginalized or
they can't be who they are dale
mentioned teachers teachers are
something else we need my mom's a
retired school teacher my aunt's a
retired school teacher my brother's a
teacher everybody everybody here in the
family and remembers teachers who've
impacted their right and i've met
teachers who have left the profession
because they can't cut it in terms of
the pay it just doesn't work for them
and we've heard so many teachers left
during the pandemic there's a major hole
in the public education system what do
you say to young people today thinking
about that career how do you get good
people into the profession you know this
is the most impactful look all of you
said with smiles on your faces yeah this
person's a teacher yeah listen we're
here because of a teacher
and it's our responsibility to lift the
profession and as secretary of education
i'm taking that very seriously we need
to increase uh teacher salary to make it
competitive uh we need to make sure that
the working conditions are conducive to
to growth professional growth personal
growth uh the days of teachers missing
three to four hours of their own family
time to correct papers we need to
revisit that the days of teachers paying
out of their own pocket money for basic
supplies second jobs but not only that
their working conditions um but voice as
we're reopening and reimagining schools
let's make sure our teachers are at the
table to talk about what schools should
look like so i'm really excited about
where we're going with education i to
the young folks to answer your question
get in the professions is the best time
to become a teacher so that's my line
thank you so much really nice to have
you here thank you thank you don't be a
stranger